So now our Boolean formula that we are building
as it inputs to SAT is going to become even larger.
So as you have seen before,
the calculation that a non deterministic RAM makes
for a given input can be represented as
a polynomial number of snapshots,
and I'm now going to draw the snapshots only like this;
you know that represents the input, the program,
the read-write memory, as well.
We've already seen that the state of the
non deterministic RAM at each point in time
can be represented as a snapshot
and that snapshot
can be represented as the Boolean formula,
so now that we found out how we can encode a snapshot into a Boolean formula,
let's go back to our main mission,
showing that any problem
that can be solved on a non deterministic RAM
can be encoded as a SAT formula.
And the idea of this is to build a huge--
well, not that huge; it's all going to be polynomial size,
but it's still going to be very large,
so the idea is to build a very large Boolean formula
as follows.
each timestep of the algorithm
is going to be represented as a snapshot.
Then we're going to ensure that
the first of these snapshots
represents the memory of the RAM at
t =0.
What that means is that the program starts
at the first line of execution
and of course that memory contains the input
that we're giving to that program or algorithm.
Then thirdly, we have to ensure that the snapshots
fit together.
What I mean by that is even though it's a non deterministic RAM
if at a certain point in time,
say  t = x,
it is in a certain state,
then at the next timestep,
t at x plus 1,
there's only a limited number of choices
or potential states that machine can be in.
So if we were having a deterministic RAM,
actually as we already said,
the state of the machine added time point x
already clearly determines what state the machine will be in at point x plus 1.
For a non deterministic RAM,
if you use the if better operation
then there can be 2 different states at the next time point.
And then finally, we have to ensure that the Boolean formula
that we're building has an input to SAT
can only be satisfied
if the algorithm returns yes at some point in time.
Otherwise, because we have a decision problem, if the algorithm returns no,
we do not want the Boolean formula
to be satisfiable.